One thing that's always on my mind is...
...what if, in my deepest, worst moments of self-doubt, I'm right?
What if I really am hideous?
I know owl's feathers are beautiful,...
...but every time I think of myself from a third person perspective,...
...it's like I'm back in middle school.
I know I'm not an awkward, hideous mess now,...
...but if I really think about it, can I be sure?
Can I?
And I'm not talking about how owls eat.
We all rip our prey apart with our talons or just swallow them whole.
It's gross, but we don't have teeth, so it's not our fault.
Plus, we always eat alone.
Okay, maybe I'm not okay with the whole eating thing.
I do think I'm okay with the whole poltergeist, head spinning thing.
Yeah, it's off-putting,...
...but the first time you see it, it's kind of cool.
It's like the tablecloth trick.
Do it all the time and you're a weirdo,...
...but the first time you do it, you're a freaking magician.
I mean, I'd rather be cool once than a mess all the time.
But you know what gets me?
The fact that I'm a mess all the time.
Fun fact: I have three sets of eyelids,...
...one for sleeping, one for blinking and one for cleaning.
I have cleaning eyelids, can you believe it?
It's like biological proof that I'm hideous.
I hate being an owl.